the Super Bowl is as much about the
advertising as it is about to football
sometimes more so I mean what did you
see more tweets about Peyton Manning or
the walking intestines you never know
when I BSD will show up every year
brands spend millions on epic ads that
beam their products and slogans directly
into your living room I've seen things
but this year was way less about TV and
more about the internet more to the
point your phone take jeeps commercial
the stark photos of American icons were
displayed in portrait orientation on
your TV that left Big Black chunks on
either side but it fills your phone's
vertical screen I've outrun robots and
while coke sad stretched to every corner
of your set it also dropped clues about
how to buy collectible mini coke cans
that you can't get in regular stores you
had to watch that thing over and over
and follow coke on social media if you
wanted one
you could almost call it a secret
formula within a secret formula well
played coke advils low five spot was the
opposite of a polished TV ad it looked
like something your aunt dropped in your
facebook feed of course it wasn't but
it's grainy videos and normal looking
people definitely fit in and while von
Miller made the game by stepping on cam
newton creative agencies brought in an
MVP of their own babe words printed all
over your screen from budweiser to
paypal it was a clear strategy to craft
media for Social Feeds where video will
likely play without sound the biggest
winner yesterday is actually your
smallest screen